protein is an essential nutrient the
body needs it to make things like
enzymes hormones receptors motor
proteins and build muscle we acquire
protein through our diet in foods like
eggs meat fish nuts and even protein
powder really any source of protein is
acceptable for your diet except for one
specific protein molecule you want to
avoid eating it consists of two protein
chains totaling 529 amino acids is
sourced from a seed native to East
Africa and a few milligrams of it can be
lethal this simple protein is none other
than ryen you may know about ricing due
to its use in the crime drama breaking
bad but aren't sure how it works in this
video I'll discuss how and why this
simple protein molecule is so dangerous
to
consume this is the dark science of
[Music]
ryson
but first the sponsor for today's video
xter exter makes highquality personal
and travel Essentials such as wallets
backpacks and accessories that go above
and beyond expectations I got their
Parliament wallet which comes with a
carbon fiber card holder and a solar
powered card tracker both the parliament
wallet and card holder are smaller than
a conventional wallet hold 12 cards plus
cash blocks are ID skimming and has this
Nifty release to access your cards the
coolest part about this wallet is if you
lose it you can track its location using
the solar powered card tracker a 3-hour
charge lasts a full 2 months and is
voice activated using Siri Alexa or
Google exter is also environmentally
conscious their wallets are made with
environmentally certified premium
leather and comes in six different
colors with the wallet carbon fiber card
holder and card tracker you can carry up
to 12 cards plus cash prevent RFID
skimming easily access your cards and
locate your wallet if it's ever lost if
you're not sure what to get someone this
holiday season the extra wallet makes a
great gift just the easy card access
alone makes it worth it get up to 55%
off using the code dark science xer.com
and check out the Black Friday sale from
November 10th up until the
26th ryson is made of two linked protein
chains called rysen toxin a and rysen
toxin B each protein chain plays a
different role in the toxic effects
Ricon has on the body both proteins must
be present and bound together for the
Ricon to be toxic for example barley
grains contain the same protein a toxin
found in rysen however there is no
protein B toxin attach to it making it
safe to eat without protein B rysen
cannot get inside cells and cause damage
let me let me rysen can enter the body
through ingestion injection inhalation
or even dissolving into mucosal
membranes in the eyes as an Airborne
dust the protein has a tightly packed
structure due to disulfide bonds that
make it resistant to destructive acids
in the stomach once in the body the
ricent toxin B protein binds to a
glycoprotein called an aetl
galactosamine on the surface of cells
when toxin B attaches to this
glycoprotein it triggers the cell to
engulf the entire Rin protein into the
cell chemical kinetic Studies have found
about 107 ryen molecules combined to the
surface of a single cell once inside the
cell vesicle shuttle risen to the GGI
apparatus here an enzyme called
disulfide isomerase cleaves the
disulfide bond joining the toxin a and
toxin B proteins once separated rysen
toxin a has an enzyme pocket that
becomes exposed allowing it to function
as an enzyme toxin a is then released
into the cytoplasm where it reeks havoc
on the cell in the cytoplasm are organel
called ribosomes which are responsible
for assembling amino acids into proteins
these newly assembled proteins go on to
become cell receptors enzymes hormones
Etc on average ribosome synthesized
about 42 million protein molecules per
cell without without functioning
ribosomes a cell cannot live once in the
cytoplasm toxin a binds to the ribosome
and Cleaves an Adine molecule from it
this Adine molecule is needed to
stabilize amino acids while they're
being assembled with the Adine molecule
now gone amino acids aren't stabilized
and proteins cannot be assembled as a
result the cell cannot make make new
protein ryen toxin a is able to perform
this enzymatic activity at an alarming
rate owing to its toxicity kinetic
Studies have shown that a single rice
and toxin a protein can deactivate up
to, 1500 ribosomes per minute all of the
important products protein is made into
such as enzymes receptors motor proteins
Etc are no longer made in the cell now
with deactivated ribosomes cells begin
to shut down over several days this
results in slow and agonizing organ
failure taking on average 3 to 5 days to
cause
mortality there is no known cure for
ricing poisoning there are vaccines that
allow the body to generate antibodies
that stop the protein from entering
cells unfortunately ricin vaccines are a
specialty vaccine and are hard to get
ultimately survival is dependent on the
dose of rysen a lowd dose usually causes
localized organ damage whereas a high
dose causes systemic organ failure
though low do is not fatal it can cause
permanent damage to vital organs such as
the liver kidneys and lungs oddly enough
though ryson is highly toxic it hasn't
found much use in the military this is
because ryen is difficult to deploy
effectively and breaks down in longterm
storage nonetheless ryson has found use
in smaller scale applications perhaps
the most famous use of ryson as a weapon
was in the 1978 assassination of
Bulgarian dissident and author Georgie
marov marov was a Bulgarian writer and
broadcaster who fled Bulgaria for the UK
in 1969 at the time Bulgaria was under
communist rule by the USSR once in
England marov published critical
articles and broadcasts about his
experience under communism on September
7th 1978 while waiting for a bus on the
Water Bridge in London marov was shot in
the leg with a pellet fired from a
fabricated umbrella gun using
pressurized CO2 the pellet was filled
with ryson and sealed with a sugar
coating when it penetrated the skin and
entered the bloodstream the sugar
dissolved releasing rysen into the blood
with an hours marov became Gravely ill
and was checked into a hospital doctors
were unable to diagnose marov being
unaware of what had happened marov
passed away on September 11th Just 4
days later during the autopsy the
coroner found a pellet lodged in the
back of markov's leg the pellet was 1.7
mm in diameter was 90% platinum and had
two holes drilled in it which held the
Ricon now that we know how Ricon Works a
more important question follows where
does it come from ryen is found in the
inner oily tissue of the castor bean a
flowering plant native to East Africa
Castor beans are grown to extract castor
oil from the bean as it's 50% oil by
weight castor oil itself is used
medically as laxative and moisturizer
luckily since the rice and protein is
hydrophobic it does not dissolve well in
oil and is not not found in Castor oil
however for safety regulations castor
oil is heated to 176 F prior to being
sold temperatures of 176 F denatures
ryson denaturing causes the protein
chains to fold and bend making it a
completely different protein that is
non-toxic the majority of Ric actually
remains in the dried crushed Bean Mass
called oil cake the rice protein must be
extracted and purified from the oil cake
to be used which won't be discussed in
this video for obvious
[Music]
reasons sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws Us in are
topics that are dark maab or terrifying
it's with the intention of this video
that you too were drawn in and sought to
have your questions answered thanks for
watching Dark
science